Let's try one with
a little bigger smile.
[rushing sound]
[dial tone]
[gagging]
[dramatic sounds]
[gun clicks]
[horn honking]
Oh my god.
Shh.
You see all that,
it didn't happen.
[electronic music playing]
Microsoft didn't
literally kill anyone.
They were coming
hard after Netscape.
And in a fashion element,
the gangsters say,
that was pretty gangsta.
[inaudible] shady.
It's sleazy.
Sleazy?
Last time I checked, was
antitrust level illegal?
I was ready for a fight.
We can't force the
DOJ to prosecute,
but we can give them all
the ammunition they'll need.
Back then, Hollywood
was interested
in internet streaming.
Michael Fenne.
Also known as
David Kim Stanley.
What a pleasure.
Pleasure is all mine.
He started showing off
the same technology to
a whole new crop of investors.
Wow.
MICHAEL FENNE (ON LOUDSPEAKER):
Who's ready to become rich
beyond their wildest dreams?
[cheering]
He sparked off
internet IPO mania.
Do we even want
his $5 million?
Do we want $5 million?
We believe $40 million
valuation is fair.
[yodeling]
We're going to drink,
and we're going to dance.
And you're going to have
the time of your life.
All right.
Some of the
parties were insane.
[cheering]
People were maybe
overindulging.
[inaudible] was throwing
$100,000 parties before
they'd even earned a cent.
The biggest red flag
is throwing a party.
Big, gold letters--
iBash.
iBash was this massive
concert in Las Vegas.
To iBash.
iBash!
The biggest star-studded
musical event ever.
and in your home, pitch perfect.
Write that down, pitch perfect.
It was not possible to use the
Pixelon technology to pull off
something like iBash.
Nobody can compete
against Microsoft.
This crazy battle that's now
being called a browser war.
Creating this browser was the
only thing that mattered to me.
You're welcome.
Your job is keep
running as fast
as you can toward that cliff.
My job is to keep
moving the cliff.
MICHAEL FENNE: He's a reporter
doing a story on iBash,
and you're going to
have a front row seat.
Everyone with an
internet connection
is going to have a
front row seat, right?
[dramatic music playing]
You're the guy who's
making all this fuss?
You guys ready for your
lives to change forever?
- 5--
- Doesn't mean it didn't work.
I'd like to report the
setting of a fugitive.
4--
There's a judgment coming.
3--
It's over.
It's far from over.
2--
[dramatic music playing]
1.
MICHAEL FENNE: We all
going burn in hell for what
you're trying to do to me.
[dramatic music playing]
[computer sounds]